good morning everybody welcome to reason
weekend it is awesome I haven't seen
this much excitement in the morning
since I think my first a a meeting i'll
be working all weekend uh apparently
here so welcome to Santa Barbara as
David not was mentioning last night
Santa Barbara has a lot of great
resonance for the history of Reason
which we will get into tonight with a
great conversation with Bob pool and
super McCann and mana Klausner which I'm
super duper excited about it also has a
resonance and nostalgia with me that I'm
going to inflict upon you now in the
guise of talking about the modern unfree
speech movement that we're dealing with
so I went to school at UC Santa Barbara
this is an iconic image of it 12 miles
to the north here that is stork tower
where 100 s thompson may or may not have
engaged in illicit activities in 1987 if
i remember correctly the over here was
the place where i learned how to do
journalism at the UC santa barbara daily
naxos at the time it was one of the five
or so best daily newspapers in the
country the year a few months before i
joined the staff in 1986 they had
published a series of expose a's showing
that the Chancellor then chancellor of
the university had misused and
appropriated university funds to build a
new bathroom and a bunch of other kinds
of weird corrupt things a series of
expose that eventually put him in jail
and got him out of of the Chancellor
hood robert hutton back who incidentally
is the uncle of mickey kaus for those
who like weirdness the nexus seeded a
lot of people the managing editor of the
LA Daily News for a long time is a
former next side the woman who works for
the ACLU who talks to Edward Snowden
every day
selfie stick as a former person I worked
with they're all kinds of interesting
guy who ran Sony Pictures publicity for
20 years a very a thoroughgoing
wonderful place where I learned a lot
about journalism it wasn't the only part
there this so Thomas stork of whom this
is named for is a great old character in
Santa Barbara and California history if
any of you can find it in a used
bookstore online there's a great book
that he wrote called California editor
talking about his time he bequeathed
this area as a gigantic free speech
factory basically so you have the daily
nexus right there you have Casey SB the
campus radio station which brought the
world or inflicted upon the world people
like Jim Rome and Steve's Saban among
others which is all funny because it's
basically a bunch of old commies playing
like folk music from Cuba but you have
these shock jocks that came out of it
Thomas truck had this great idea about
free speech he was the publisher of the
Santa Barbara Daily News which was a
democratic paper in the early 20th
century the Republican paper called the
Santa Barbara press was always
foundering and in the onset of the Great
Depression they really are desperate to
have a buyer for it and so they sold it
to Thomas torque and so the guy you know
what are you going to do if you have
both newspapers here in town you're
going to combine them right no he didn't
he thought well you know what we should
have but we have a democratic paper
there's enough Republicans in this town
we should have Republican paper too and
even though it loses money I think it's
more important for the quality of debate
to have both papers so for six years
during the Depression he ran both
newspapers one of them which was
bleeding money and he did from his own
concept of free speech eventually they
didn't merge and become the Santa
Barbara news-press much later but
anyways he bequeathed this great space
and sort of a great sense of freedom to
the UC Santa Barbara campus which
extended beyond just a little media
center there the film school errors was
very interesting it's a highly
theoretical and and and I swear it's
good even though it did produce a
Gwyneth Paltrow there's there's a
College of Creative Studies started by
crazy hippies in the in the 70s I think
it was where you don't get grades you
just have to show up and constantly
produce
work art music a bunch of stuff a lot of
great musicians came out of that so at
the time that I was going there and then
in the late 1980s it was this font of
great sort of discussion and and
production of free speech material we
had our share of controversies to be
sure on what some of which we'll get
into later I recall my freshman year a
little gentle man named Eric Boucher who
was dating a copy editor at the at the
nexus but whose stage name was jello
biafra and he was a crazy punk rocker he
came in and gave a huge lecture about
why I'm glad the Space Shuttle blew up
um which created a some kind of
controversy at the time blue velvet the
movie was out that year and there's a
big vigorous debate on campus about
whether it was objective I objectifying
women in this abella rosalina Rosellini
and things like that um there was a new
feminist movement a group called you
can't keep a good woman down and I was
covering all this at the campus
newspaper was fascinating who went into
a crappy liquor store called SOS liquor
which probably is still standing and
tore down I think they were topless if I
if I have this correct so they're
topless and they came into the SOS
liquor store and tore down st. Pauli
girl posters remember the same public
girls you're like no because they were
objectifying and dehumanizing to women
and so we we dealt with a lot of these
uh kind of vibrant free speech issues
and usually on the end especially after
at the newspaper but elsewhere the kind
of notion that hey look this is a open
brawl this is how you know we we move
the needle on things that's the best
outcome so for example this obscure
person named sean hannity who worked at
kcs be was charged with being anti-gay
hate speech ER because he I think he
compared homosexuality to bestiality and
said you know anyone who believes that
homosexuality is normal is a crazy
person and you shouldn't listen to him
and so there's a big debate and
um the daily nexus who's nicknamed by
the way it was commie rag so give you a
sense of it's a of its politics
generally speaking although we altered
that during a my tenure for sure I let
to the guys defense and said hey look
you know we should have in addition to
lesbian folk ballads from the Soviet
Union we should also be able to have
guys like Sean Hannity he eventually was
kicked off the air at that time in a
divided vote and maybe a precursor of
things to come so I used this all as a
backdrop UC Santa Barbara was a very
interesting place a cradle of kind of
free speech and debate things like that
and now I'm going to subject you to a
wonderful recent TV video for four and a
half minutes which also takes place in
reason in UC Santa Barbara that tells us
how far we've back slid in some ways on
free speech on college campuses gentle
boys do you have our region 2 DVD what's
harming getting just a small warning
certain scenes do trigger certain
emotions it's really not anyone else's
business to tell someone when they are
mentally and emotionally ready to deal
with things if you create a sort of a
sense of a duty for a professor not to
say anything that potentially could
trigger an emotional response from
students you are really severely
limiting the world in which a professor
can teach
have you ever been shocked by a violent
or disturbing scene in a movie book or
on the internet good now i was thinkin
maybe you could have used trigger so a
trigger warning warranty about content
you might be facing that could provoke a
response based on symptoms of PTSD the
concept of the trigger warning first
gained popularity among feminist and
social justice blogs some of which
include extensive lists of possible
triggers ranging from depictions of rape
and abuse and war two needles and snakes
and small holes one site even lists
potential triggers in films such as
American Psycho which contains core
murder and sexual violence against women
or it takes to which alludes to the
death of a parent child abuse and child
labor a few enterprising college
students are now pushing to bring
trigger warnings to the classroom I was
in a classroom was a very small intimate
classroom and we're watching a film and
there were several scenes of sexual
assaults and finally a very drawn-out
rape scene it did not trigger me I
recognized the potential for it to be
very triggering Bailey lover in as a
student at the University of California
Santa Barbara and while Oberlin has
attracted a fair amount of media
attention with its wide ranging list of
triggers that encompass racism
colonialism religious persecution
violence suicide and more it's actually
love reigns more focused UCSB initiative
that's gotten the most traction passing
the Student Assembly and soon to be
implemented as a mandate for all
professors I don't feel like it's a
problem asking for this to be mandated
that this should be an official policy
you're always going to have someone
that's going to argue why this is this
is ridiculous I should ask you this
because I don't feel it why should
anyone else well the majority people are
already willing and actually
implementing this in classrooms this
reaches out to the people that have not
yet done so if universities had a
trigger warning saying if you want to go
to two universities then be careful
there might be stuff that triggers you
you know that would be sort of absurd at
some level but ultimately if you're
going to college that is a way of saying
that
you're ready to talk about some really
serious issues being uncomfortable being
upset being even a little bit offended
is different than having a panic attack
blacking out hyperventilating screaming
in a classroom feeling like you're under
such physical threat whether it's real
perceived that you act out violently and
from other people the National Institute
of Mental Health estimates that about 3%
of the adult US population suffers from
post-traumatic stress disorder the
Mental Health Network psych central says
that ordinary events can serve as
reminders of the trauma and trigger
flashbacks or intrusive images that
means almost anything in daily life
could be a potential trigger for someone
but Lovering has a plan for that the way
the resolution was written it directed
the office of student advocate which I'm
a part to consistently review and revise
this list with the assistance of the
Resource Center for gender and sexual
diversity the women's center and the
Counseling and Psychological Services on
campus I've been working defending
freedom of speech on college campuses
now 4 for 13 years and the problem with
creating sander that says broad and
vague as the one that they're talking
about at UCSB and the one they already
have it oberlin is it very quickly gets
co-opted to limit discussion and to
punish people who have points of view
that you really strongly disagree with
how far can the trigger argument be
taken just a couple of weeks after the
resolution passed the Student Assembly a
women's studies professor snatched a
sign from some pro-life protesters and
then pushed one of them away when she
tried to take it back her stated reason
for doing so what she argued was that
the display was triggering and it's an
unfortunate part of human nature if you
give us a refuse a sort of an excuse to
shut down speaking which we disagree
we're very quick to jump on that you
know we see it as an opportunity
so let's hear a little bit about the
rest of that story too because it
actually gets worse there was a petition
signed as online petition so take for
what it is by 2,000 students defending
the professor against the protester
saying that the professor's right that
she was micro aggressed and and as a
result you know we need these these
people to leave and then it still gets
worse because the Chancellor of the
University Michael Young not the former
UC Santa Barbara baseball player Michael
Young but the Chancellor the University
I Michael Young issued this incredible
letter on which he was talking about you
know our founders gave us the right our
founders by the way who were all white
men seriously was this kind of language
gave us you know freedom of speech and
and we should think about it but what we
really need to do is to beware of quote
Outsiders coming into our midst to
provoke us to taunt us an attempt to
turn us against one another as they
promote personal causes and agendas he
just had a professor one of his
employees shove a sixteen-year-old I
mean this was a tiny girl shoved to 16
year old anti-abortion protesters take
her property rip it up destroy it and
the Chancellor is saying but we really
think abouts these outside agitators
coming in and violating our space by
being all divisive II and such for those
of us with long enough memories the
phrase outside agitators in the UC
system is kind of hilarious because the
entire free speech movement this thing
that sprouted up and UC Berkeley in the
early 1960s and kind of launched the new
student left some of which had some
salutary effects and others descended
into nonsense but the free speech
movement on Berkeley was all about being
able to talk about politics particularly
war on campus which was not possible in
the 50s and early 60s and the people who
try to crack down on this Clark Kerr at
the time and particularly this Bay Area
legislature nightmare person named Don
mulford always talked about outside
agitators it's all these outside
agitators coming on there
mists and they're going to try to return
the youth he launched a bill in 1965 to
quote remove from the campus the
professional agitators the beatniks the
mentally ill the untouchables and the
unwashed I think Nicholas because
classified in every single one of those
or at least I for the [ __ ] so how in the
hell did we go in in a half century from
broadly speaking the kind of campus left
rallying around the notion of a free
speech movement that needed to and did
ultimately expand the zone for free
speech do you have these mealy-mouth
Chancellor's and also students and
everybody else talking about trigger
warnings and all these kinds of things
you can't read this slide but I canceled
that's why it's here I the 50th
anniversary of the Free Speech Movement
was this the beginning of it was this
year and so the now Chancellor of UC
Berkeley Nicholas Dirks also issued an
incredible kind of open letter thing and
I'm just going to read it because the
language of this is when I used to live
in Central Europe we talked about this
thing called communists its key yeah
Zeke in other words communist language
which existed way after communism
because people had been born and raised
in this just awful burying the lede kind
of bureaucratic nonsense talk and you
could just you could smell it from a
mile away and this sort of reminds me
it's not communist but there's something
to the language of this okay as we honor
this turning point in our history it
isn't what this is for the free speech
movement okay this is a big deal Birger
as we all miss turning point in our
history it is important that we
recognize the broader social context
required in order for free speech to
thrive for free speech to have meaning
it must not just be tolerated it must
also be heard listen to engaged and
debated yet this is easier said than
done for the boundaries between
protected and unprotected speech between
free speech and political advis advocacy
between the campus in the classroom
between debate and demagoguery between
freedom and responsibility this guy went
to the Barack Obama straw man school
here of a have never fully been settled
as a consequence when issues are
inherently divisive controversial and
capable of arousing
strong feelings the commitment to free
speech and expression can lead to
division and divisive pneus that
undermine a communities foundation
really he said this it's remarkable and
we see this around us every single day
literally in March this kind of thought
has led to most famously the two frat
boys being kicked out of university of
oklahoma after tape emerged of them
saying awful things on UC irvine student
body band flags earlier this month
because flags are common obviously that
you American flag is the is the big
offender here are symbols of oppression
and obviously you know might be able to
trigger people I was just you know on
for the sake of fun saying I wonder if
we have a college free speech headline
and reason calm this morning we do at
the University of Oregon and
anti-abortion preacher had his sign
forcibly taken from him by students who
said quote this is not part of your
First Amendment right which is
interesting gets worse and then a police
officer came by and he said and this is
all captured on video I presume what I'm
here to tell you is that on campus we
have additional rules other than just
freedom of speech so they're enforcing
these new kind of things this happens
every single day we are seeing this it's
a new wave unlike we had seen arguably
since the late 80s and early 90s so how
do we get to this bizarre place one way
is that my generation kind of lost the
fights we were fighting as I mentioned
all these kind of things but as with the
sean hannity the result was he would get
kicked out and I'm no great fan of Sean
Hannity to say the least but you should
have his own for free speech at the time
that this was happening you're all these
discussions about how pornography leads
to violence and there was a new kind of
crack down on on it that was widely
noted and at the same time this was
going hand in hand with the creation of
ethnic and gender studies requirements
which doesn't necessarily cause anything
but these were seen by people
by activists as two sides at the same
coin we need to crack down on speech and
we need to mandate these things the
woman's studies professor from UC Santa
Barbara that whole department existed
because there was a hunger strike that I
covered to establish the beginning of an
ethnic and gender studies or requirement
and department at UC Santa Barbara
another thing is that the PC thing that
we all talked about those making
headlines everywhere and 1993 and such
like that it never died I had Greg
Luciano Friday an article for a reason
about five years ago with that exact
headline I think it the the germ of that
article became his a great book on
learning Liberty um it kept going the
proliferation of campus speech codes
went on and has continued on when people
stop covering it's like the workplace
drug testing remember when everyone was
like my god or drug testing at work this
is a big thing in the 1980s as
journalists started having to be drug
tested and they're pissed off about it
they'd write about it at some point
since they all had to take the drug test
they stopped writing about it and it
continued so a PC and these speech codes
and free speech zones and cages and
things like that have been going on and
then also I think that there's a new
thing to observe it's particularly in
the Age of Obama I don't know how much
of it is related to just the fact of of
politics that are surrounded around him
but I salon.com which was founded in
nineteen ninety-five i believe it was
very interesting publication back then
it was Camille Paglia who's who's sort
of career took off as a backlash against
these kind of joyless speech restricting
kind of things she was a columnist for
salon com hey David Horowitz was a
columnist for salon com all kinds of
things that don't make sense for those
of us who who follow it now they saw
themselves back then as a lot of
liberals of the the ilk of Bill Maher
saw themselves it's like pullet we're
going to be politically incorrect we're
going to say whatever we want and we're
going to talk about sex differently and
we're going to be fearless we're going
to shut down the the buzz kills on the
left I'm not shut them down but we're
going to you know demonstrate a new way
of talking this was much more kind of
standard-issue boilerplate left now that
the salon calm besides running every
single
they you know why libertarians are the
next Adolf Hitler it's all identity
politics it's why this joke in the
Academy Awards is problematic because
you know hey look he asked the black
woman to look at the box during the
broadcast and you know that's a that's a
braai actually talked about that on
MSNBC for like ten minutes actually I
didn't talk i had my ear harangue about
the problematic jokes of neil patrick
harris on the academy awards because he
was making jokes involving black people
and he's not black um even though he
wasn't saying hey look at that black
person it stunning so a new republic
which has just undergone all kinds of
different things like that has decided
that it's going to go down the salon
calm path and so now in addition to
their why libertarians are or Hitler 2
point 0 articles which are almost daily
it's all identity politics all the time
arguably the 2012 reelection of barack
obama was very much fought not on any
kind of record to defend but on the
sense that republicans were coming after
disfavored communities women minorities
everybody else like that so it has that
type of identity politics it's just
really noticeably swollen over the last
six to eight years in ways that I think
have curtailed the zone for speech so
does it matter what people say on
college campuses I've always been of the
mind that basically not maybe that's
because I was kicked out of college for
bad grades but I don't spend a lot of
time you know on college campuses but
I'm starting to believe now that the
broader culture of free speech that has
been emanating from there and that is
sort of out there in the public has now
caused things that are starting to harm
the rest of us I think we saw this wood
for me the real low point of the Obama
presidency besides the way in which
Obamacare was passed and and what it is
it was his speech in front of the UN in
2012 i believe it was a couple of weeks
after the Benghazi thing where he says
you know a free speech in the world must
not slander the Prophet of Islam money
said must the administration basically
blamed Benghazi on
a crazy YouTube video by some Rando dude
in cerritos and they still stick to that
largely as the reason for what happened
and put them in jail you know so there's
a real sense now the the notion that
speech can be a trigger can be a
provocation on is has entrenched in the
State Department when when the embassies
and consulates are being sacked in Libya
and in Egypt and a Pakistan the State
Department was sending out serial
tweeting out serial condom nations of a
YouTube video they were under attack and
they were saying we you have nothing to
do with this provocative you know a
YouTube video it's a it's insane to me
Charlie Hebdo I think we saw and then
the international scale I think we're
seeing a lot of backsliding on speech
there's that great and very moving you
know mass protest or rally after the
Charlie Hebdo massacre in Paris
including a lot of you know free speech
champions like the head of Saudi Arabia
and Turkey but even worse than that no I
don't mind when people are feeling the
need to pay tribute to stuff that they
don't necessarily believe I think that
means that the that stuff still is kind
of winning but the French government
responded to this by launching a wave of
arrests against people for facebook
posts like scores of arrests there's a
clownish anti-semitic comedian named do
dinnae and in France who walks around
giving this solute called the canal
which is made to look like the Nazis
loop but you can't actually do the Nazi
salute that's illegal in France so he
does this other thing he's always like
up pushing the boundaries he was
arrested after the wake of Charlie Hebdo
because he said just we charlie and then
the last name of one of the guys who
shot off the kosher deli I mean it is a
terrible person but to respond to this
by cracking down on speech says to me we
need to win more arguments broadly in
the liberal west than we're doing FCC
net neutrality I think it
is actually sort of part of the whole
concept that we've right now the left
does not see the government as a problem
with speech someone was telling me last
night and I'm going to blow the anecdote
so i'll just drop it but but along those
lines talking to people to me it's it's
astonishing that the very same people
who defend edward snowden and who hate
government surveillance then want the
government to make sure that all the
internet is run like an electric company
it says to me that people have sort of
lost the the connective tissue between
what actual censorship looks like so i
think that these micro campus trends are
creating a bad sort of culture of speech
that is worth talking about and fighting
back against and it's also led to a due
process nightmare when it comes to
sexual assault on campus and tangible
laws the obama administration sent out a
list of directives to to college
campuses tying funding with reducing the
standards evidentiary standards for
kicking students off for alleged sexual
assault this has led to a wave of just
awful on due process cases of people who
were not allowed to testify on their own
behalf and all these kinds of things
Cathie Jung wrote this story it's one of
the most popular stories we've run and
during my editorship about a year and a
half ago here and it's literally you're
guilty until proven innocent here and
laws being passed California passed a
law New Jersey and New Hampshire passing
laws about affirmative consent requiring
I mean you have state lawmakers in
Sacramento making lists of how one
should engage in heavy petting on
college campuses the contracts that you
need to sign this is crazy so since this
is reason weekend and we are in
California I think it's important to
note that some reason for optimism about
all this stuff yes it's bad it's a
backsliding thing um but one thing is
that this stuff is just not popular
right like it is at some point it is
inherently ridiculous when you can't
laugh at at Neil Patrick Harris making
jokes
wart welcome to the 87th Oscars tonight
we honor Hollywood's best and widest
sorry brightest MSNBC which has turned
it its whole broadcast channel into
finding perceived grievances against
disfavored minorities on their ratings
tanked and now they're just firing
people right and left and and realizing
that that was not a ratings winner there
is idle if you watch the Saturday Night
Live 40th anniversary which is pretty
good there's a great moment when Jerry
Seinfeld came out on Seinfeld has been
been criticized pretty heavily about how
he never had black people in a show this
kind of stuff and he took questions from
the audience and he took questions from
a black comedian who woman who's to be
on SNL saying oh you know addressing why
didn't you have more minorities and
other people represented and he just
said yeah our show wasn't about solving
the world's problems next there's a
there's a there's a sense that like come
on are you kidding this is it's not fun
I mean when you're walking around
policing jokes all day long it's not an
attractive pose to people and I think
that's like no one loves a television
show because it tries really hard not to
offend people I think we see the the
opposites of it another reason for
optimism fire literally wins every
lawsuit it files and its filing more and
more lawsuits when Greg wrote his piece
for us five years ago he commented that
of the 13 legal cases that they had
taken about campus speech codes and
these kinds of things they had one all
13 13 and oh is a pretty good record and
I think that I don't know if they've
lost any major ones since then but
generally speaking the First Amendment
as a backstop has worked pretty well in
these cases and continue and will
continue to I think even the Harvard Law
Faculty has been protesting about the
the due process speech rights on campus
as relates to sexual assault so I think
in the culture these are winnable
arguments in the actual conditions the
legal conditions for speech given the
First Amendment
also given a Supreme Court that is
pretty damn good on free speech most
robustly we've seen a long time and just
the stuff that you know the fact that
it's not popular i think there's plenty
of reasons for optimism